regardez ces images du lycée Simon nous
nous rejoignez
regardez ça c'est les toilettes oui mon
avis de classe incroyable incroyable on
dirait une école abandonnée regardez
alors regardez ça les élèves
c'est fou si vous nous rejoignez à 20h55
on est en direct et vous avez dû suivre
cette affaire de cette école sans
électricité également regarder
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on a les images
des élèves qui sont avec leur portable
pour suivre les cours s'il vous plaît
avec la lumière de leur portable si vous
avez ça en régie s'il vous plaît merci
en photo merci si vous pouviez aller un
petit peu plus vite merci en gestion je
vais venir le faire moi-même
merci
s'il vous plaît merci
c'est fou alors aujourd'hui merci à
Flora d'être là vous êtes scolarisé au
lycée au lycée wallon donc ce lycée tant
qu'elle classe je suis en Première
première alors raconte nous ce qui se
passe dans ton lycée parce que nous on a
Lucine tous les gens ont vu des images
aujourd'hui tout le monde s'est dit mais
c'est impossible c'est incroyable bah du
coup bah on est au lycée voile et on est
dans des salles qui sont dans des
conditions pitoyables on n'a pas moi ça
fait trois ans que je suis au lycée
depuis et même des personnes avant moi
ils ont dit que c'était pareil ça fait
des années que ça a pas évolué du tout
et là bizarrement depuis des médias il y
a eu quelques changements vite fait dans
les robinets ou dans les plafonds et du
coup bah on est dans des salles avec
aucun chauffage par exemple ce matin
j'ai dû passer un DST de 3 heures je on
a dû garder nos gants pour pouvoir
écrire moi j'ai écrit avec mon manteau
sur mon dos parce que j'arrivais pas
j'avais trop froid on arrive dans la
salle il fait de la même température à
l'intérieur de la salle que à
l'extérieur
il fait super froid et c'est horrible
ça fait trois ans que ça dure quoi on va
nous dire qu'il y a des travaux mais on
a fait la grève l'année dernière aussi
et vous dites quoi Valérie Pécresse va
faire que le lycée aille mieux mais ça
va pas du tout mieux
ça ne s'est jamais arrangé c'est du
camouflage qui fond dans ce lycée et nos
enfants oui vont en cours et travaillent
en cours avec un manteau
en première aussi et un autre en BTS
c'est un lycée professionnel
technologique et il y a les BTS aussi et
un internat il vous racontez et vous
racontiez rentrer à la maison vous
raconte il vous dit quoi aujourd'hui il
a eu deux heures de sport dans un
gymnase du lycée qui n'est pas chauffé
il a fait sport en doudoune
les cours de sport ont été banalisés
parce que les profs n'ont pas voulu
faire cours dans ce gymnases il faisait
8 degrés et ils ont banalisé du coup les
courses ce matin je pense pour le reste
de la semaine tant que ils n'allume pas
les chauffages dans la salle propre
autorise le manteau mais d'autres profs
non plus et ça crée des conflits il y a
des rapports qui sont créés
son manteau alors qu'il fait et quand il
vous dit qu'il est obligé de s'éclairer
avec son téléphone c'est quoi cette
histoire
souvent des coupures d'électricité c'est
pas nouveau non plus ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui ça fait trois ans ça qui a
pas d'électricité dans les couloirs il y
a les lumières s'éteints que j'en étais
un film d'horreur là par exemple on a dû
écrire
on a dû écrire avec les flashs parce que
l'électricité ne marche pas il y a
beaucoup de moments aussi où les
projecteurs vont s'éteindre les
ordinateurs ne marchent pas les fenêtres
ils sont cassées il y a des trous dans
le mur il y a peu d'isolation c'est des
conditions dans lequel moi je ne peux
pas travailler j'avais du mal à
consacrer je comprends Amel quand votre
fils vous l'a dit au début vous l'avez
cru ou pas vous l'a dit je fais les
conseils de classe donc j'ai vu le
l'intérieur du lycée c'est réel c'est
pas des montages c'est vraiment vrai ce
qui se passe dans ce lycée c'est
horrible et je me demande comment les
enfants arrivent à travailler moi mon
fils il a eu son bac l'année dernière là
il est en BTS cette année mon plus grand
je me demande comment il a fait pour
avoir son bac et franchement je leur
retire mon chapeau c'est gamin qui
l'abandonne pas l'école parce que c'est
super difficile de travailler dans des
conditions pareilles
je me pose la question si dans le les
beaux quartiers de Paris c'est c'est
comme ça et les professeurs ils disent
quoi et professeur ils sont comme nous
ils disent ils n'en peuvent plus
parler aujourd'hui avec des journalistes
il se cachaient la direction etc c'est
grâce au prof du coup que là en puissant
parler ici parce que des preuves qui
vont envoyer des messages qui essaient
de changer quand même les conditions
dans lequel on est et qui essayent de
contacter l'éducation nationale aussi
parce que non on a essayé de contacter
le rectorat
de l'école vous avez été voir c'est un
nouveau directeur d'accord ils ont que
lui déjà il est arrivé il avait le lycée
dans cet état voilà donc il a dit quoi
avec lui là il va les recevoir ce soir
d'accord voilà mais après tout ta page
médiatique oui va recevoir les parents
d'élèves mais voilà avant tout ce qui a
été médiatisé il disait quoi mais rien
je vous dis on a fait grève on s'en
plaint il disait ça va tout va bien
les travaux sont en cours
les travaux sont en cours ou pas
ce drapeau
il y a aucun travaux il y a un chantier
à côté de la porte d'entrée mais à part
ça il y a aucun projet de travaux pour
le bâtiment on a eu des travaux fait
dans les autres bâtiments il y a des
nouveaux bâtiments mais il y a aucun
travaux de projet de travaux en tout cas
pour notre bâtiment les toilettes ne
sont pas fonctionnelles aussi au-delà du
chauffage parce qu'on parle du chauffage
mais il y a beaucoup d'autres problèmes
[Rires]
je vous jure c'est une anecdote vous
raconter souvent des anecdotes mon grand
mon fils il avait besoin de faire la
grosse commission j'habite à 15 minutes
à pied mais 5 minutes en voiture il m'a
appelé viens me chercher je suis venu le
chercher il a fait sa du temps à la
maison et je le redéposé à l'école
c'est incroyable je vous jure c'est
c'est pas normal ce n'est pas normal
c'est fou parce que c'est clair moi je
dois aller jusqu'au bâtiment dès que du
coup que ça me prend 5 minutes pour
aller jusqu'au bâtiment
pendant les cours je reviens 10 minutes
plus tard parce que du coup les les
robinets c'est des jets d'eau on peut
pas vraiment se laver les mains les
fenêtres sont ouvertes ils sont cassés
dans la salle de bain du coup on a super
froid dans la salle de bain dans les
toilettes c'est parfait
qu'est-ce que vous auriez à dire ce soir
à Geoffrey carvalino conseiller régional
du 93 mobilisé pour les lycées ils
travaillent avec Valérie Pécresse il est
celui qui s'occupe du alors qu'est-ce
que vous lui diriez ma chère amie
Valérie Pécresse vous allez vous êtes là
pour nous contrer
non moi je suis là pour discuter pour
vous expliquer et surtout vous dire ce
qui est en cours mais nous on a la
marque des difficultés également pour la
Seine-Saint-Denis parce que aujourd'hui
on va parler de Olivier concrètement
après pour la Seine-Saint-Denis
moi je moi je comprends quand on voit ce
genre d'image même à votre place moi
j'ai été lycéen Saint-Denis j'ai fait
toute ma scolarité donc vous étiez au
lit moi j'étais à La Courneuve
quand on arrive en 2016 à la tête de la
région on a récupéré 270 vetus sur 470
en Île-de-France et donc on a fallu
mettre le paquet dessus pour rénover les
lycées on a mis 5 milliards on a rajouté
un milliard ce qui fait ça
wallonne on a entrepris des travaux à la
demande du maire de AULNAY
je suis désolé
2018 j'ai été moi-même je vais commencer
les premiers ont lieu dès 2017 en 2017
monsieur et en 2018 il y a eu des poses
de première pierre je suis allé moi-même
avec la déposer des régions
du lycée
inauguré monsieur Hanouna des internats
en fait pour que les jeunes en
bénéficient c'est vrai que ça prend du
temps mais vous savez quand vous faites
des marchés publics quand vous avez le
retard du haut covid vous avez également
des problèmes de pénurie de certains
éléments pour construire et bien
effectivement ça prend du temps
on repart de on repart de très très loin
certains images qui ont été diffusées je
suis désolé de vous le dire mais
certaines images ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui ici
aujourd'hui
le reste c'est en rénovation on est
pleinement mobilisé
et ça prend du temps et moi je vais vous
prendre un autre exemple
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de passer devant les toilettes en
faisant comme ça qui a pris la porte en
réalité c'est bon pourquoi ils ont pris
la porte la gauche en 2015
mais je vous explique pourquoi on est
reparti de très loin les solutions elles
sont sur la table il y a aucune raison
aujourd'hui la région était mobilisée
d'ailleurs
connu il y a eu tout de suite une prise
de conscience les le vice-président est
allé sur place le maire
d'Aulnay-sous-Bois est complètement
mobilisé
madame pour faire il n'y a rien de
concret monsieur
mon fils a passé son bac dans des
conditions comme ça avancer ce lycée
n'est pas tout à fait la réalité et même
la semaine dernière on a eu un conseil
d'administration de ce lycée avec des
représentants de la région et des élus
on nous a nullement fait remonter ce
genre de problème on a eu cet après-midi
des représentants de parents d'élèves
qui nous ont pas décrit la même
situation je vous invite aussi
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui on met
nous le paquet pour rénover ce lycée
mais c'est pas évident ça prend du temps
alors
du mal à comprendre
acceptable
je vais te donner à manger mais ça va
prendre du temps on va attendre que tu
sois mort et ben
la vidéo date d'aujourd'hui je vous jure
je vous croisez toutes ces vidéos
aujourd'hui j'ai pris toutes ces vidéos
aujourd'hui
il est dans cet état là ça c'est c'est
ce qu'on dit
une menteuse
ici quand même et moi-même je suis allé
dans ce lycée parce que vous savez tous
les ans on remet des ordinateurs au
lycée 1 moi même
donner des ordinateurs à nos enfants on
ajoute 525 millions d'euros qui se jette
pour rénover on a mis 7 millions d'euros
depuis 2016
on va pas avancer nous on est là pour
trouver des solutions vous savez un peu
ça oui plateau qui vendent du rêve qui
vend du vent mais nous on est là pour
faire c'est différent on sait que c'est
pas évident moi je viens sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui je sais que c'est pas
évident mais je viens de dire tout ce
qu'on fait on met l'argent sur la table
on met le paquet pour que notre jeunesse
réussisse vous savez moi je suis fils
d'ouvriers j'ai grandi ensemble
vous êtes très sympathique monsieur
on tombe dans un discours de politique
exactement toujours
la vérité on s'en bat les couilles
on veut savoir où en sont les travaux et
quand est-ce qu'ils vont pouvoir avoir
des portes et des des électricité oui je
vous ai répondu le calendrier est très
simple les buts alors voilà c'est ça
voilà merci on peut parler mon parcours
parce que quand vous êtes élu et que
vous agissez tous les jours pour que
améliorer le quotidien des gens ça
compte aussi me souhaiter et je sais que
vous non plus vous avez pas eu des
moments facile vous étiez de
Seine-Saint-Denis et vous allez bien moi
et heureusement monsieur
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui comme je vous
ai dit il y a des travaux qui sont en
cours qui sont mises en place 47
millions d'euros voter et que ça prend
du temps c'est vrai c'est difficile mais
vous verrez à la fin vous serez content
parce que ce quartier est bénéfice
vraiment de chacun
de la réalité vous parlez de la santé
allez vivre
ça madame
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qui sont en cours une partie qui est
déjà rénové un tiers qui va être l'an
prochain et ensuite à l'horizon 2026 de
2007 parce que comme je vous l'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure
Cyril Hanouna
aujourd'hui il y a eu des réactions
d'ailleurs
représentante de parallèles on a des
conseils administration on n'a pas eu
ces remontées on allait plusieurs fois
dans ce lycée on fait tout ce qu'il faut
pour faire réussir mais effectivement ça
prend du temps je vais vous prendre un
autre lycée vous pouvez vérifier c'est
le lycée fédère à Épinay-sur-Seine ça a
mis des années à être construit c'était
une vraie galère et et et c'est vrai moi
je peux comprendre on a vu les chantiers
c'est très compliqué et aujourd'hui
quand vous allez dans ce lycée FEDER et
bien les parents demandent à ce que
leurs enfants viennent dans ce métier
parce que sinon
je pense que c'est un sujet très sérieux
en tout cas ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'on est pleinement mobilisé et
si tous les lycées de la région de
France c'était dans ces talents je pense
que
blablables
c'est que du vent vous croisez que du
vent la réalité c'est ça nos enfants ils
vont à l'école franchement
il y a d'autres problèmes
alors dites-nous c'est quoi les autres
problèmes comme ça le professeur qui ne
sont pas remplacés mon fils a des
dernières étaient en spécialité physique
il n'a pas eu le prof de physique
pendant trois mois provoque
l'éducation nationale pas en
Seine-Saint-Denis il y en a pas dans 93
c'est pas vrai on n'êtes pas là vous
êtes élus certes je sais pas qui vous a
élu mais il y a pas d'action pour nous
en fait on est des abandonnés de la
République Monsieur les profs ils sont
venus avec des casseroles devant
l'éducation nationale ils ont rien fait
on n'est pas entendu
justement nous la région on demande qui
mettent des moyens en place souvent la
région vient notamment je vous prends
tout à l'heure vous prenez en exemple
les ordinateurs de la région sur
d'autres sujets sur l'insertion
professionnelle sur plein d'autres
sujets on vient en fait faire nous la
région ce que l'État ne fait pas en
réalité et on se mobilise dessus
là vous m'attaquez la politique
politicienne
vous dites c'est normal ça prend du
temps c'est pas possible de prendre du
temps là il faut qu'il y ait un camion
demain qui arrive et puis il faut
attaquer les travaux c'est pour ça que
demain
ils ont remis les plaques au plafond ils
ont changé
[Applaudissements]
pour que tout d'un coup ce qui prend 5
ans exactement
depuis quelques semaines d'ailleurs
ils avancent sur les travaux comme il y
a quelques ça prend du temps à un
chantier de rénovation
je comprends je comprends pas vous êtes
un fils d'ouvrier vos enfants sont fils
ouvriers non son fils est un élu ils
sont dans quelle école vos enfants
madame j'ai pas encore la chance d'être
papa vous pouvez pas parler
moi de deux enfants qui vont dans ce
lycée H24 de 8h jusqu'à 17h30 il n'y a
pas de chauffage il n'y a pas de
toilette il n'y a pas d'eau il n'y a pas
de professeur il n'y a pas de sécurité
il n'y a rien nous sommes abandonnés par
vous les élus de la République je peux
pas vous laisser
on est en 2022
je suis d'accord avec vous vous allez
pas choisir le carrelage non
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que tu préfères non mais c'est
vrai non mais franchement il a raison
vous savez ça prend du temps
[Applaudissements]
on a rénové plus d'une vingtaine de
minutes on a ouvert
on a eu trois lycée de Seine-Saint-Denis
qui ont été ouverts aucun département de
France on en a trois autres qui vont
arriver d'ici 2027 jamais personne n'a
été aussi fort sur le département de la
Seine-Saint-Denis on fait la région de
France
vous le dire là on est sur un plateau
télé mais la réalité il n'est pas tout à
fait la même chose aujourd'hui
on discute il y a un conseil
d'administration la semaine dernière et
on agit concrètement il y a des travaux
c'est difficile pendant les travaux
[Applaudissements]
pardon mais quand même
moi ça va pas prendre de temps
et l'expression c'est une vanne merci
jean-marcoto va la crêperie avec les
chaussures
du coup bah comme vous le disait ça fait
cinq ans moi que moi ça fait trois ans
que je suis dans ce lycée ça n'a pas
changé du tout je vais ça prend du temps
oui ça prend du temps
il voit les images c'est vrai que c'est
on aimerait nous juste avant là avant
qu'on se quitte que vous nous donniez
des échéances voilà juste parce que le
courage de venir ici quand même mais on
veut savoir voilà demain qu'est-ce qui
va se passer vous pouvez faire les
travaux demain
non mais c'est vrai
concrètement
il va avoir deux semaines de vacances
est-ce que est-ce que pendant les
vacances vous pouvez pas accélérer les
travaux qui puisse venir à la rentrée
avoir un lycée convenable on va on va
agir concrètement vous l'avez reconnu
tout à l'heure
on peut faire des choses un diagnostic
qui va être fait des choses des choses
avec les élus et les parents d'élèves et
tous ceux qui concernent le lycée
vous avez sacrifié cette établissement
elles ont raison il y a d'autres
établissements que vous avez reconstruit
parce que vous en faisiez une priorité
celui-là vous l'avez sacrifié le
bâtiment que le plus touché aucun
travaux prévu aucun travaux prévu
donc maintenant monsieur arrêtez avec
votre truc il y a des millions
des vacances je pense qu'on pourrait
déjà avancer pas mal en 15 jours
vous savez on va on va
il y a des échéances on peut pas 2027
c'est pas possible non mais 2025 son
fils
excuse-moi de te dire ça
la prison de région est pleinement
mobilisée elle l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure
en tout cas on va suivre ça on est viré
par exemple
il y a
le lycée
quelque chose
bien aussi
[Applaudissements]